hey guys welcome to the Ruben report I'm
the guy who set up all of CNN's plane
programming Dave Rubin and I've got Bren
moer and Trayvon free with me here we go
all right uh Ukraine have you heard
about this we got a situation Brewing uh
they have officially seceded in Crimea
from the Ukraine they voted they're
joining Russia 97% just shy of the 100%
that Kim Jong-un got in his reelection
bid in North Korea pretty good right
uh there was an interesting oped in USA
Today by Ron Paul not ran Paul he's hot
these days but it was by Ron Paul about
what the US's role in Ukraine should be
what's the big deal opponents of the
Crimea vote like to point out to the
illegality of the referendum but
self-determination is a centerpiece of
international law article one of the
United Nations Charter points out
clearly that the purpose of the UN is to
develop friendly relations among nations
based on respect for the principle of
equal rights and self determination of
peoples perhaps the US officials who
supported the unconstitutional overthrow
of Ukraine's government should refocus
their energies on learning our own
Constitution which does not allow the US
government to overthrow governments
overseas or send a billion dollars to
bail out Ukraine and its International
creditors okay so I thought this was
interesting because you're not going to
hear anything about Rand Paul's feelings
on this uh in the news but I think he
does sum up sort of the way a lot of
people feel like what the hell does this
have to do with us that's sort of how I
feel how do you guys feel what what
should our role in this place that's
halfway across the world be yeah I don't
know I mean I sort of disagree with Ron
Paul in this which is I think this is a
big issue and the world focus should be
on this right now I think this is a
really important moment geopolitically
when the borders are shifting and we
should be paying attention and I think
if it wasn't for so much focus on the
Malaysian plane I do think we would be
paying attention so I mean that's my
take on it and you know Ron Paul and I
sort of disagree about a lot of things
so you think the 25h hour a day coverage
of the plane is a bit too much is that
what you're saying no I mean I'm I'm
into the plane coverage but I also just
think that this is this is an important
moment it's an important moment for the
United States it's important moment for
Europe and it's a important moment for
for the Ukraine certainly in Russia all
right so we'll talk about why it's
important but first do you put it in
that category somewhere I no I
definitely agree I mean forget the fact
that Ron Paul is the guy old man on his
lawn yelling about the thing in the
paper he saw this morning and then out
fires while he's doing it yeah but I
mean you can't ignore the fact that a
country was just taken back by another
country because they saw a hole in the
gate like it's literally like the guy
next door is Putin and he hears you and
your wife arguing and he goes well
here's my chance to go take this guy's
wife because there's they they're
fighting so I can get in there and like
why that's that's serious to like you
can just take another country like what
year is this right so so what should our
role be though because I I'm with you
guys that yeah he should not be doing
this and obviously the 97% that voted
for it obviously that's but
what should we do are we gonna arm you I
mean John McCain saying we should arm
Ukraine angry old speaking of an angry
old man we'll top your angry old man
Angry old man who he just get your gun
every no matter what the situation is
get your gun but don't don't you think
that Ron what Ron Paul saying that does
sort of resonate with a lot of people in
the United States right now just this
idea that we just shouldn't be all over
the place whatever is we're only going
to make it worse I think that's sort of
the the I I mean that's a valid point I
think too but you know Ron Paul is also
you know has argued on the other side of
that fence a lot of times where there
should be sort of intervention and
certainly John McCain who argues for
intervention all the time I mean this is
it's an opportunity that the the world
should be just focusing on attention and
paying attention to this sit would argue
for intervention in Cupcake Wars John MC
would argue for intervention this right
now yeah um but don't so don't you see
this as sort of that Putin just feels
like he can do whatever he want using
your analogy so so right and I think you
can't uh you can't be America and not do
anything because you're America and
everyone's like you're the supposed to
be the one who who helps us when we are
another country's in need like what are
we supposed to do like America help us
and so when you do nothing Obama's weak
and he is uh unresponsive and then when
he does something it's not the right
thing so as a as the world superpower we
have to I mean it's because the bush
Iraq thing kind of burned out our
tolerance for intervention anywhere and
so we as a country have to realize put
that behind us we have to focus on
what's Happening Now and we have to deal
with problems that arise in the world
that could affect us in the future no
matter what happened in the past and if
that means intervening in another
countries whatever it may be we have to
examine that and I also think that you
know this isn't this is maybe the first
opportunity where Putin is sort of
putting back together the the Soviet
Union and so we just have to pay
attention to that I think both from you
know political standpoint and also from
a human rights standpoint which this
could cause a refugee crisis I mean this
could be a serious and I'm by no means a
hawk but this is a moment where I think
like you know let's let's keep an eye
out and see what happens here is the
scary part to this whole thing that
maybe Sarah Palin and Mitt Romney were
actually right about something is that
is that truly the scariest part it's
totally a broken clock is right twice
the day kind of thing where it they just
so happen to really fall in their lap
and I mean if you look at the look at
the opening ceremonies it was really
Putin pining for the USSR like really
like this is what he wanted and he's
trying to get the band back together
yeah yeah um is is the other problem
here that this is sort of unmasked once
again I think that the UN is just sort
of pointless when it comes to doing
pretty much anything because we veto
things on the security Council we don't
like Russia now invades another country
vetos things that they don't like so
really it is just up to us cuz we're the
last Super so if we don't do anything
it's sort of we're damned if we do
damned if we don't cuz there's nobody
else but us the UN is good at blocking
traffic in New York when they have
people in town that's the one thing
they're really good so that one week
when they have the general assembly
they're really really good atut really
good at shutting down the city east side
yeah uh is is there any point in the UN
at this point I still have a lot of love
for the UN despite the fact that they
brought kalera to Haiti which was a
personal issue in Vendetta that I had
against the UN but I still think there
is a place for a a world body that can
try to speak uh with a unified voice and
a little bit of Reason here and there I
think they've been ineffective a lot um
there probably needs to be a lot of
Reform but uh it would be a scary world
I think that didn't have a United
Nations yeah definitely all right well
let's talk about President Obama and
some poll numbers as long as we're
talking about Ukraine because he's
getting hit B basically on both sides
people saying he's not doing enough he's
doing too much so uh a new CNN orc
International poll came out about
Obama's numbers 57% believe
uh leaders of other countries no longer
respect Obama 50% see Obama as a strong
and decisive leader 50% do not there's
also a roughly 5050 split on whether
Obama inspires confidence 53% say he's
tough enough to handle a crisis and
77% say he's
likable um let's start with the likable
part cuz that that is right like that's
the thing this guy this was a cult of
personality that we all voted for I
voted for him twice um hope change we
all still like him sort of more than the
policies is that fair to say that
number's High though isn't it that's a
high that's really high 77% we'd all
take that i' take that in my own
family uh no I think he's I think he's
still incredibly likable you know he's
that that he's opened the White House up
to be an accessible place and that
family seems to be one that everybody
really loves and respects um you know
it's the other numbers they're pushing
vegetables on us that's true except for
the vegetables and the bike helmets and
mom jeans it's a pretty normal American
family but I you know it's the rest of
the numbers that I think are problematic
for for for sure I mean I mean look at I
think and I say this a lot when you look
at the numbers about what people think
about him as a person as a leader I
think it really boil down to the fact
that they just hate him they've hated
him since before he was inaugurated the
first time and so to me those numbers
don't really mean anything because for
one every president's numbers do this
over the course of their presidency but
I mean for him he's had such a tougher
Mountain de climb when you face
opposition before you even swear into
office so how do you measure the
effectiveness of a man who's constantly
being blocked like how do I know what
works and what doesn't if I've never
seen anything through really I mean so
the important number isn't the 77% the
likable number but it's the other
percent which is the the hate number is
so is so big that so roughly do you
think it's about 23% that just hate him
no matter what it's probably you think
that's I think that's probably the bare
minimum yeah absolutely I would I would
say that's a given and then you you look
at the fact that they obstruct him for
the the simple fact of obstructing him
and so it's hard for me to judge him as
a leader when I haven't really seen him
lead I mean at least when Bush was
president the Democrats would okay you
want to do this we don't like it but
we'll see it through we'll see it
through there's some game play along
little let's play along a little bit for
the sake of not shutting down the like
and so I can't really say with 100 100%
certainty how I feel about his
leadership or his decisiveness when for
one who the are we to talk about
the decisiveness of the president of the
United States like do you know how hard
that job is like who are you sitting on
your CS like yeah man that Obama guy no
matter even if it's like even if it's a
a republican like you don't know how
hard it is to be president no matter
what party you're in he doesn't get a
chance to give you a poll number and how
you do your
job get the way you made those fries 33%
I mean I've had better fries in other uh
other times but I don't really I mean I
do know that Obama is a big fan of the
show and has clicked like many times on
a lot of our videos that's the likable
somebody somebody on YouTube named
Barack Obama just spelled slightly
differently do you think so to that
point do you think he gives a flying
about numbers at this point
especially because he's almost entering
lame duck status if he's not already
there I just saw this morning that
already they're planning this move to
Hillary already with some of his people
and Biden's already pissed about that so
do you think he cares he looks at these
numbers he's like I got two and a half
years left or whatever it is and I'm do
the hell I want I think he sees this
that 77% number and he's happy about
that but I think he total I mean how
could you not care when you get numbers
coming out all the time that says you're
you know ineffective or you're wimpy or
you wear mom jeans or whatever it is
that the 23% level against all the time
yeah you gotta and you can't punch
anyone no you you have to take it like
they're calling you out and you have to
sit there and take it you don't think he
just like slaps Biden every now
and again just something I hope I hope
so I hope he has a punching bag or
something in the office cuz right to me
that number that's interesting is that
57% number that we talked about which
was they you know they were saying what
was it 57% of Americans believe that
other leaders find him uh wimpy or weak
or what it is that number is crazy how
do you even determine that number how
does CNN even find that number how is
they not
100 like because they are the leaders of
of course they're going to think that
the other leader is weak or a wimp like
no one's going to come out and go man
that Obama he's so strong and so
confident I wouldn't want that guy to
try yeah I would never want to fight
that guy I mean we love you Obama we
love but should they take the poll
against other world leaders instead of
what just middle Americans think that
the
leaders that's an interesting number
what's not an interesting number
somebody in Minnesota saying like oh I
bet like the president of Uganda thinks
he's not very strong like it's like who
cares what that guy thinks they don't
even know who these presidents are right
so isn't this one of these things that
goes back to the Ukraine thing where
it's like he's damned if he does damned
if he doesn't because you can do more
and then they'll respect him more but
then we'll be in a war so it's like how
do you pick do I want to be in a war I
don't want to be in or do I want to be
liked right and that's that's a tough
choice I think the number would be
interesting if it just said 57 Americans
can name another world leader and then
we
like Baptist churches in Paduka Kentucky
which was the site of a high school
shooting back in
1997 are hosting quote Second Amendment
celebrations and giving away guns and
Stakes because you got to have a steak
if you're going to have a gun uh to
attract more people to their
congregations I am not making this story
up it is actually true uh let's take a
look a little video from the local Fox
affiliate forgive me but I never really
heard of uh churches giving out guns to
get guys to sit in the pews man you just
been out of touch you you f we've been
doing this 20 years this is in Paduka
you know Paduka Kentucky so you know
what happened in Paduka uh I've heard
about that so did you know about that
before you plan this a little ironic a
little insensitive the the issue is not
the guns the issue is men's hearts and
uh men who have their hearts changed
through a personal relationship with
Jesus Christ will handle guns
responsibly Chuck does seem like a very
spiritual guy doesn't he uh well don't
worry folks it's not just happening in
Kentucky it's happening in New York too
Upstate Troy New York uh according to
the LA Times there's a church there
that's giving away an assault rifle this
very weekend we've got the
flyer yeah you can win a free
AR15 my peace I give unto you John
14:27 uh March 23rd yeah they're going
to give away freaking assault
rifle I mean is this literally just the
worst of everything in America like like
somehow that they've combined
spirituality and religion and guns and
fear
and it's like Jesus always said turn the
cheek and reload yeah exactly and then
fire back like how do you like how weak
do you think your stance is or or your
God is if you have to attract people
with guns like if your message if you
believe that heavily in Jesus Christ and
the love of the Lord and you can't do it
with the Bible right that you have okay
here's a gun here's a steak what do I
have to give you here's two tickets to
see that night you know Carnival day
didn't work they like what more do how
do I get you to love my Lord and I guess
religion in a way is often about bribery
one way or it's almost literally
bringing you to Jesus at gunpoint yeah
it is the Bible is like the shield for
the bullets and then you got your gun
and the steak when I was watching this I
was thinking look if if a Jewish temple
did this that would just simply never
happen and can you imagine if AOS
Muslims said we were giving away guns
people would people's heads would
literally we should just try that I
think and see what happens really can
you imagine lose their minds the end of
it the end of it Fox would literally
spin off another Channel Al together to
just deal with that constantly but it is
an interesting point because the rest I
mean you know I bet there's a lot of
other churches and congregations and
nraas who are rallying around these
churches who when people are you know
crying that this is a bad idea or this
is you know an political or whatever
there are probably churches out there
who are coming around this saying like
we should protect our you know our
rights and this is something that a
church can do but yeah God forbid if it
was a mosque it would be the end burn to
the ground how is it the the heart test
how does that work when you're giving
someone a gun like he has to have a good
heart it's like it's like the time when
when Bush said he looked into Putin's
eyes and saw into his like saw into his
heart like what the does that even
mean does that but okay so then
beautifully so okay so the quote there
was my peace I give unto you and that's
so they're using a biblical term to try
to sell you a gun but what's the
connection I not P makes sense the other
piece yeah it's the other piece no but
really like what what are they going for
there like I I guess somehow they're
implying my piece I give to you in that
I'm going to weaponize you so you will
protect yourself because I guess God
can't protect you when it comes down to
it if someone's breaking into your house
he's too busy uh picking who's going to
win the final four so you got to arm
yourself and especially month yeah like
I mean it's just I it's one of those
stories that it comes out and you have
nothing to say it's so it's so terrible
and you go this is I mean you know this
is a snapshot of a of America today and
it's it's it's terrifying and maybe
what's worse is they're giving out this
steak which is probably so pump full of
hormone that's a whole other we'll get
to some food stuff later yeah yeah yeah
it's all GMO and all that stuff um all
right so just to finish up with this
where do you guys generally stand on on
the gun thing I've been trying to ask a
lot of the panelists that we've had on
just a general thing because I feel like
our debate about it is so stupid so let
me get two rational people where do you
generally stand on the gun thing well I
think as a country we are so far gone
over the second amendment that taking
away guns is never going to happen so I
think you really just need really good
rational gun reform and that's all you
can really do here like you're never
going to be Australia or England because
people will go crazy if you tell them
we're going to get rid of guns so I
think it really comes down to just
really good solid form so that people
can have them but maybe not a machine
gun but you could have a rifle to shoot
a deer I mean I I have a family who is
in Maine who are hunters and they rely
on that for their food in the winter so
I can't be so against their ability to
be able to hunt but I think when the
second amendment was written it was like
muskets that they were talking about
right so maybe people should be able to
have a musket if you have to put there's
a powder and then commercial where the
guy tried to do an office shooting with
a musket and that was the joke like
while he was reloading everyone was gone
right right but is is mus is the
argument against that though that these
people genuinely think that one day
they're going to have to form a militia
to fight the government so they would
argue well if the government has tanks
we do need machine gun they watch too
much TV many movies they're like they're
losing the bunker the those people
doomsday prep like they're going nut
they're driving themselves insane with
this crazy illusion in their mind right
we're going to be beating down the door
trying to get them baked beans I I
honestly believe that if the gun if the
NRA would like team up with like the
walking dead people and sell it to me as
you're going to need this for the zombie
invasion I would be much more prun than
I am right now but how many do you need
how many guns do you need you you don't
need you don't need an AR-15 to
hunt the zombies the zombies but that's
my point okay I think we solve the gun
thing right there all right let's uh
let's move on Two and a Half Men is a
horrible show have you seen it it's
really just terrible it's apparently
it's still on which I cannot believe
Charlie Sheen is long gone they have
Ashton Kutcher now and uh I guess the
half men the kid he's off the show
entirely uh Angus T Jones uh he left the
show after ranting against the show and
calling it filth uh we've got a little
video of him telling people not to watch
in the first place I mean Jake from 2
and a Half Men means nothing he is
nonexistent character
he's 2 and a Half Men if you watch 2 and
A2 men please stop watching 2 and a half
man I'm on 2 and a half man I don't want
to be on it please stop watching it a
poor kid he made millions and now he
realizes it's philth doesn't want you to
watch anymore but now look at him it
looks like he's turned into someone from
Duck Dynasty and that was making light
of topics in our world that are really
problems for a lot of people and I was a
paid hypocrite because I wasn't okay
with it but I was still doing it so he
left but in hindsight he says he could
have approached it differently you know
that's his that's his like his baby and
I just you know just totally in insulted
his baby
and and to a certain and and and to that
degree I am apologetic but otherwise I'm
I'm not uh I don't regret saying what I
said the he he's talking about there is
Chuck Lori who is the creator and
executive producer of Two and a Half Men
um I I think the story is kind of
fascinating cuz first off this show is
still on the air Two and a Half Men one
of the men left now the half kid left I
mean I don't know what's going on with
all that uh what what do you make of
this like that he's try is he on rum
Springer he looks like a
need shower yeah like he's going half
crazy like how how does how do you sit
there and take all that money I bet he
didn't give it back did he give the
money back and that's the Crux of it
it's like are you giving the money back
like don't sit there and talk about the
hand that fed you for however many years
buy a razor
right exactly like get a Gillette like
don't and don't give the money back but
not only give the money back obviously
he's still getting residuals so it's not
just it's not just that he got a chunk
of this money five years ago he's going
to probably for the rest of his life I
met in his mind he's like I'm gonna use
that money to spread the word so I'm
taking I'm I'm I'm Shifting the use of
this bad thing that I did and I'm not
going to use the money for whatever
frivolous thing I'm going to use it to
spread my new message so I'm actually
using Chuck Lor's money for good right
maybe he's doing that I got to defend
like I like that kid doing that sort of
moment like that and that first shot
where he's wearing those like Malcolm X
classes it's cool man like I'm I'm into
people who have these kind of Awakenings
where they're making a terrible show for
like a a terrible Network that's really
filling people's minds with you know
terrible you know crap anyway and then
all of a sudden he wakes up and he
becomes a a fanatic I I'm into Fanatics
like I think it's just is more
interesting than just standing up and
getting another you know Teen Choice
Award or something like that I wish we
would have had video of him between the
Malcolm X stage and then the Duck
Dynasty stage there was an in between
stage you could tell something happened
there I am I am on board I'm on board
the idea that you're saying of like if
he truly believes that it's look we all
pretty much I think I can speak for all
us we think a show like that is crap um
so if he really believes that I kind of
there's some credit I want to give him
it's cool right anybody who really has
like a strong belief like that like you
got to you got to give it up to that kid
for standing up for I mean even though I
probably don't agree with whatever his
politics or whatever it is but like it's
kind of cool that at least he stood up
and said something like it's pretty punk
in that whole thing yeah so are we are
we being too glib about this Angus T
Jones uh no you can have it I don't know
I I find it pretty hilarious like I mean
I definitely agree I mean you got to
give it up to someone who can wake up on
either side of a thing like the people
who come out of the westbo Baptist
Church I mean you want it to happen you
want it to be a possibility Cameron it
happened to KT Cameron oh my God like
that is insane the guy think the guy
thinks a banana fits in your hand and
that's how God ex that is ridiculous
yeah there's a great KK Cameron banana
video we will link to it in the
description um is it is it just too easy
though to on Hol hwood and and hit
and the the lifestyle here and the
message here I I've been here for a year
and I guess I probably had some of those
preconceived notions of it's all these
elitists liberal whatever and I've
pretty much only met really good people
but not only that I don't get a sense
that they're pushing any agenda other
than they want to sell programming I
don't get a sense that there's like a
real message or some unified thing going
on behind the scenes so is it just too
easy to to attack Hollywood like that I
mean look that Two and a Half Men show
had Charlie Sheen on it forever who was
just who's an you know and who
you know was not great to women in his
life or was not you know probably used a
lot of drugs publicly so like I don't
know maybe the kids got a point which is
he had really great to the women or
depends that was the problem yeah I
don't know I mean I I I agree with you
that I don't think that this town prozes
or pushes some message like that but I
still I still got like a little love for
that kid when he stands up and grows his
hair out and looks like a weirdo and
stands up and does interviews and you
know takes takes a takes a a hit on the
chin for like believing in something
which I think in this you know maybe in
this town it's rare that somebody
believes in something with that much
conviction that they're willing to stand
up against everything else that's right
I'm yeah exactly you're not you're not
yeah um why is it that everyone that
suddenly goes the religious route starts
looking crazy what's that why can't he
have made the move said okay I'm done
with this thing I'm going to keep that
first Malcolm X look maybe even get just
get warie Parker instead of that that
look but you know what I mean like why
do then the hair why why does that all
come in one pack it seems like once you
go the jump to the crazy religious train
they like hand you a starter kit yeah
it's like here's your beard here's your
crazy glasses they take away your
conditioner and your sh here's a script
of the things you want to start out
saying so that people pay attention yeah
and then probably fade off Into
Obscurity yeah I don't know if you guys
saw uh real time this week but Bill Mah
did a great thing on religion as usual
where he talked about you know you've
got these Orthodox Jews that in the
middle of the summer are wearing wool
hats Mormons can't drink hot chocolate
on a cold uh Winter's day and it's like
and now you got this kid who looked
pretty normal and now I mean he looks
like a mountain man yeah yeah he looks
like the American Taliban or the the
other version of it I think there you go
all right let's talk about rewiring our
brains Because the Internet and
technology and phones it is actually
doing it to us uh let's look at eight
ways that technology is rewiring our
brains we now dream in color which we
did not do a long time ago we're going
to get to that one in a little bit uh we
experienced fomo do you guys know what
fomo is you two hipsters yeah fear of
missing out that's right Phantom
vibration syndrome which I think we've
all had in our pocket right now uh we
can't sleep that's a big one uh our
memory and attention span aren't that
great I really want to talk about that
one uh we have better visual skills we
have poorer impulse control we create
more so these aren't all terrible some
of these are actually good if we have
better visual skills and we're creating
more and connecting with people in
different ways so let's just look at a
couple of these um so the the dreaming
in color one I thought was really
interesting a 2008 study found out that
adults who grew up in houses with black
and white TVs were more likely to dream
in black and white so that's sort of
like the first version of this where
somehow technology was changing what's
going on in our brain doesn't that seem
uh it seems kind of crazy actually and
then I don't even know what people were
dreaming about before they grew up in a
black and white television were they
dreaming at all like we're caveman
dreaming and all I mean who knows I I
just that seems crazy
color
youing yeah no I I I mean I don't know
that one seems absolutely crazy to me I
I can't remember any of my dreams in the
first place so I'm not I I I'm a vivid
dreamer and it's always in color and I
remember them even if you watched I Love
Lucy it's still in color they're still
in color still God I they're sometimes
crazy sometimes weird uh but yeah I've
always been a dreamer I have friends who
say they never dream but it there was a
study say everyone dreams you just
everyone doesn't remember yeah um yeah I
don't I don't I always grew up I grew up
in a house with a color TV so that's
probably why I am a color dream just
stra to your head like that watch with
the belt just like watching it exactly
so all right so speaking of dreams so
the that we can't sleep I thought this
was kind of interesting so
neuroscientists suspect that all the
lights from your iPad and your iPhone
and everything else is actually like
scrambling your brain right before you
go to sleep so you can't sleep do you
guys suffer from this at all cuz yeah I
literally just bought blackout curtains
from my bedroom for that reason because
the light it it does really like keep
you some level of awake or when you do
kind of wake up to turn over the light
hits your eyes and it makes it harder
for you to go back to sleep but now uh
the blackout curtains help a lot yeah do
you do you do of the shutdown do you
guys do the shutdown I've really been
trying like an hour before I go to bed
to stop looking at Twitter really stop
so that my brain has a second just to
well that's what trying to do too which
is that like previously into the last
like two weeks I'm terrible at it but
the the last thing that I do is look at
my phone and then the the first thing I
do when I wake up is look at my phone
and it's just it's terrible that does
send me into some not able to sleep kind
of world it's terrible cuz I'm and it's
and it sort of I think goes into the
fomo part which is that I'm always
thinking you know what happened did I
miss something what's going on and I
just can't I can't get to sleep so I'm
trying to shut that whole thing off yeah
um so we'll do one more bad one and then
and then some of the good ones so the
the attention span thing I think is the
big one I I'm finding this with
everybody that people's attention span
is completely shot you can be having a
conversation with someone right face to
face like this and then without a beat
they'll start looking at their phone
right in front of you and as and then
the conversation continues but then
they're answering slower we're all doing
it we're looking this way what you know
what I mean I'm guilty myself is that to
me this is the biggest one of this whole
thing that we're our brains are being
split into two worlds the online world
and and the offline world like I'm
usually uh like answering emails from
work or someone has texted me that wants
an immediate response and I'm like okay
I can wait or I can just do this right
now really quick while they're talking
and still listening then s and go back
to the conversation but like you heard
like 80% of what they said and it's it's
a bad habit but we all do it because
we're all our minds are in all these
different places at one time we're at
work we're with our friend we're with
this waiting for this to hear back from
some we might want to do and like all
this stuff is happening and you're just
so like w so could that could that
possibly be good cuz I think the
counterargument is that because we have
all this stuff that actually we're
starting to be able to multitask in
newer ways and that maybe the technology
will remember things for us so that your
brain will be able to use you know
you'll use that processing power in your
brain for other stuff so is that I think
it would be great if we were able to
improve our multitasking but I don't
think that that's really possible I mean
for me it's like I think it's strange
that when you get a text it it it goes
in front of the line of the person that
you're talking to right it's like when
you're at you know when you're at the
deli and you're ordering something and
somebody calls and orders something on
the phone and they go first and you're
like oh man
how do they go first right because they
call but the same thing happens now with
your phones all the time trying to send
and I just think guys are really bad in
particular at multitasking we've just
never been able to hear two
conversations at the same time or do two
things at the same time so I hope that
it makes us better but I I I I doubt it
yeah all right well we'll we'll give you
one potentially positive one here that
we have better visual skills uh the
study found out that firstperson shooter
games like Halo Call of Duty I know
trayvon's a big video game guy that they
actually boost decision-making skills
this was always my argument when I was
playing video games as a kid and my dad
would be like get outside and play out
there and I'd be like my hand I hand
coordination it's so good do do you
think there's some legitimacy to to that
argument that maybe through playing
video games and all this digital stuff
that maybe we are doing something that's
good there I love Call of Duty um I also
think there's truth to that because when
I was in college we actually had this uh
video game that someone developed to
make you a better player hand eye
coordination timing and decision making
and it was just a game it was like you
were shooting these little things and
having to time all this stuff and it was
supposed to improve the way you saw the
court the timing you you took with
passing or shooting and decision- making
so apparently there's some truth to it
right even though you could actually go
outside and pass and shoot do do all
that stuff too if you were really old
school um all right final thought on
this what about all these people that
are going off the grid do you guys Envy
them at all I I actually have someone
fairly close to me that is Off the Grid
legitimately Off the Grid and I sort of
have this real admiration for it and I
say that with all do irony knowing how
much I tweet and do a YouTube show and
all and all that stuff I'm so jealous of
it it's like a dream of mine to be able
to totally shut off somebody was talking
about this theory that they had where
they say it's something called like
using the internet dressed while you're
dressed it's this whole idea that you
know why do you use the your phone or
anything when you're lying in bed or
while you're you know in your pajamas
you should only use the phone when
you're dressed for work so I like that
theory but I would love to go off the
grid entirely I think if one of us could
do it it's defin I feel like you could
take this sweater with you yeah you know
me i' be fine I can't afford to because
I have a job that requires me to be on
the grid all the time right so well you
switch your job your job becomes like
collecting firewood then you're mountain
man yeah you grow out the Angus right
yeah exactly throwing it back the church
um do do you admire these people at all
do do you think they're doing something
I try I I try to do like okay I'm going
to go like an hour without an hour
looking at my pH like I'm it's baby
steps
but it's really hard because everyone's
always trying to contact you for
something but don't you think that you
set that up yourself I mean isn't that a
self-imposed sort of thing however you
make yourself available people will try
to get in right so if you set up those
boundaries maybe I mean I do sometimes
depending on what I'm doing will ignore
it until I have time to get back to it
but um I'm I get like emails from my
agents and people who are saying hey we
got this thing for you we need to know
like right now and even yeah and so
those are the things even though they
don't happen enough for me to be that
paranoid they happen enough that where
it's like did I miss anything because
there have been times where I miss stuff
right uh because I didn't respond to the
email in 20 minutes and so I'm like I
got this feeling of like every 20
minutes I got to see what my email's
doing I got so you just wrapped it all
up for us because you have the fear of
missing out of things that haven't even
happened and that's why you're looking
at your phone but those things bring me
money and now we have the full the
actual wrap up of the whole thing okay
we got one more for you uh we've been
doing a lot about the type of stuff you
put in your bodies chemicals that we're
putting in high fructose corn syrup is
in everything we can't have sugar
anymore you have to drink corn when
you're having soda uh and a lot about
the chemicals that we eat and uh I saw
this great list of all these crazy crazy
chemicals that we're putting in our body
with things that we eat let's look at a
couple of
them so this is dethl
polysiloxane how was that that was
pretty good you guys feel good about
that it is a chemical used in Silicon
which is found in silly putty and breast
implants uh it's also used as a filler
ingredient in chicken nuggets
Chick-fil-A sandwiches McDonald's fries
Taco Bell cinnamon twists and Diet Coke
Sprite Dr Pepper and Fanta sodas this
sort of reminds me of the pink slime
story that we've done that everybody
knows about and now McDonald's says they
don't use pink slime and they even put
that video out about their chicken
nuggets and they show you how there's no
pink slime but it's it's just great
slime it's still it's still pretty
disgusting so actually before we move on
to the others uh this stuff in
particular I know that a lot of the
commenters are going to say it's been
proven that it's fine as long as you
don't eat it constantly all the time but
nonetheless right do you like the idea
of putting that stuff in your body I
think that we are eating that stuff
constantly too which is you can't even
make that argument because most of
America is consuming all those things at
such a high high level I mean I don't
know how you look at that list of you
know Chick-fil-A sandwiches and a Dr
Pepper and think that there isn't
chemicals in those like I don't think
anybody's being like I don't even really
eat or drink anything on on that list
Taco Bell guy I feel like you're TW not
the cinnamon twist I love I have my
occasional Taco Bell they're not there's
not so many of them in New York so I
don't have it nearly as much as when I
lived here but anything on that list I
almost never have that's bad news so all
the people I'm sure I pick it up
somewhere else right right when you're
eating a yoga M or something um but so
all the people that will comment below
and say well you guys don't understand
science we've proven that these
chemicals are okay even in higher doses
than you think you think either way it's
uh we shouldn't be EA it regardless
right I mean look the fast food Lobby
and the soda Lobby are you know they'll
they can convince you that any chemicals
are fine I think that those chem those
chemicals are terrible I mean I would
Advocate that everybody you know eats
natural foods that comes from farms
nearby them and I mean that's sort of
you know as you can tell from my sweater
that's the lifestyle that I I try to
live but um you off the grid punk I know
that's what I should do I should you
should bring me into to being an off the
gritter kind of off the grit correspond
yeah now obviously everyone can't do
exactly what brand is saying for
financial reasons I want to throw that
out there cuz I every time we say that
people start going crazy about that and
that's totally legit okay let's look at
a couple others we've got lyine which is
used to improve the texture of
commercial dough for many Breads and
other baked goods the source is derived
from dissolved human hair mostly from
China of course or duck feathers I mean
how oh my God the next one's even worse
but but how do they even come up with
that how did someone think we are going
to take human hair and Design it and
then make it into a chemical that we're
going to use in who is this just mad
science it sounds like it I mean how do
you did someone like burn their hair
fell into the dough yeah and the dough
was better and they were like oh like I
didn't have time to get the hair out of
the dough but this tastes amazing yeah
and if we don't have enough human hair
let's use some of those duck feathers
that we have and isn't that funny you go
to a restaurant if there's a hair in
your soup or you freak out yet we don't
have a problem if it's dissolved and you
don't see it not a problem and now uh
the third one and this may be the wi wi
korium which is also known as beaver
anal gland juice just take a moment and
let that seep in no pun
intended it is it is natural flavoring
which basically means it's anything yeah
what is natural as long as it comes from
nature and it isn't created in a lab so
technically this is natural this is not
a chemical uh korium comes from a
beaver's anal gland and is used as a
natural flavoring in foods and beverages
like ice cream typically as vanilla
strawberry or raspberry Trayvon I feel
you know about this because before we
started the show you immediately said
the raspberry thing I saw that online
cuz I love raspberry iced tea and I was
like oh my God I should never drink who
was eating a beaver's ass and discovered
this tastes like vanilla a little bit
like raspberry right like I got to tell
someone about
this we are missing out right it's the
second guy so okay maybe somebody ate a
beaver's ass and like oh this is pretty
good I want but then he thought I'm
going to tell somebody about this I
guess it's the weird part I just don't
know how we have enough beavers in
America anymore I mean understand during
sort of The Hudson Project how do you
get them to sit
still that's that's legit they're pretty
like crazy angry animals just sit still
long enough to rub an ice cream cone on
the
butt I mean really though what the
what is this why are we doing this what
you know look I get it not everyone can
do the farm table thing not everyone
even has a Trader Joe's and I'm sure
Trader Jo uses some of this stuff but
but I'm just saying not everybody has
access to something a little more decent
but how did this happen how did cuz we
do this more in America a lot of the
stuff that we put in our food here is
banned in in the EU and many other
places what is it about American culture
well I think and I'm going to go back to
the point about you know just trying to
eat sort of a better lifestyle instead
of just saying you know oh people can't
afford that stuff I mean you look at you
need to look at the bigger problem In
America which is that you have these you
know vast food deserts where people
don't have access to um you know fruits
and vegetables and people are surviving
off bodegas with the spicy Cheetos and
and and soda like that so I mean there's
a bigger problem at hand that really as
a country we need to refocus on the
foods that people are eating because
otherwise you're going to continue to
get these kind of chemicals that are
going to be forced in I mean the
percentage of how much uh you know high
fructose corn syrup is in every single
thing that we eat is just crazy and then
you look at who is controlling that
Lobby and who's growing corn and you
know it starts to become pretty clear
that there's a you know there's a vast
corn conspiracy that's happening in
country is making people you know sick
so it's not a vast right-wing conspiracy
it's a VN conspiracy anal
conspiracy the beaver Lobby are you
going to still drink your raspberry tea
I mean after we I mean we're talking
about this now I've probably had a few
since I've seen that I mean like it's
hard to give up I think it's a I think
it's a liberty thing for Americans cuz
it's just like the soda thing in New
York where people are like you know if
it's my right to drink a 55 ounce soda
if I want to or like the people who get
mad at Michelle Obama for just saying
telling your kids to eat better or eat
vegetables sometimes like how dare you
tell me to eat good food like I want if
I want to eat butterf fried steaks I'm
going to eat but like or cigarettes
which are full of chemical that don't
stop anybody it's like they they are so
hung up on their freedom being uh taken
away that they don't realize the message
is actually good like which which which
amendment is it that you have the
freedom to have beaver anal gland it's
like six is that six what's the sixth
again I think that's the beaver gland
that's the beaver gland one um all right
final thought on this how long if we
took a caveman and we brought him here
today and we fed him our stuff does he
last two days does he die literally in
two days I mean to his to his benefit
there are those CrossFit people who are
on the cavan diet he can probably find
but yeah he would die immediately yeah I
mean does this just explain why we have
all these crazy diseases and then we
take all these crazy pills that give us
other diseases and then we take other
pills to mask the other yeah but let's
also be honest the caveman's life
expectancy was probably 17 years old at
that point so I think he'd be pretty
he'd be okay he good at the end he
looked yeah he did look
good yeah yeah we'll see we should try
it out so how long you think what do you
think two days three days well I think
yeah I think he's got like a a week at
least but he's going to be excited for
that week man bouncing off the walls
he's going to have animal style fries
he's the works he's going to have a
beaver just in his hand Beaver on a
stick all right and on that note I want
to thank Brin moer Trayvon free there
twitterers are right down below click
like comment subscribe all that good
stuff and we will do it again next week
all right
thanks